I'm Christy Turlington burns and I'm the
founder of every mother counts women die
from pregnancy and childbirth
complications around the world everyday
800 women per day so this organization
was founded as a way to educate people
about the challenges and the solutions
and to engage those people to
participate in becoming part of a
solution
90% of those deaths are preventable and
that's the part that I think when I
learned that made me see that this is
one of those things that we can do a
better job we're not looking for a cure
giving birth is the most natural thing
in the world
however 15 percent of all pregnancies
will result in a complication and so
access to people and services is
critical for every woman going through
this experience in the event that she
should have a complication to prevent
these unnecessary deaths is possible so
by educating mid-level providers
midwives nurses health workers community
health workers by making sure that women
are linked to a health care system in
that through these health workers that
should they see signs of complications
that they have access transportation
access to other services that might
require more medical interventions and
and information education and
information about one's body and sexual
reproductive health is critical to so
many women are vulnerable because they
don't know anything about how their
bodies work they're not told what signs
to look for they don't understand that
they can't do this on their own and so
information and education from both the
public as well as the individual sort of
you know woman going through the
experience and making that connection so
that women feel supported in that time
is really our goal
I was an entrepreneur in the business
space before I was an entrepreneur in
the nonprofit space and so I would say
it's a very similar experience the
difference is that in the end I'm not
selling a product per se it's a it's
it's sharing a tragedy that people can
connect with and trying to invite them
in to be a part of a solution and so for
me as an entrepreneur in this area it's
just very different in the sense that
there's number that there's there's
never that sort of you know this will do
this it's very clear that the things
that we're sort of inviting people to
share are things that make sense they're
things that anyone would wish to have
and want to have going through
childbirth and so it's more about
educating the public and then inviting
them in to participate in something
together